[Music]
every 75 years a ball of fire streaks
across the sky
but
that's no fireball
it's halley's comet and you're about to
hit your ride on it
get ready for a journey around the sun
to the edge of the solar system
and back again
[Music]
what conditions would you find there
how would you manage to survive on your
new icy home
and what would it have in common with a
trip to a hawaiian island
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you took a ride on halley's
comet
comets are the frozen remnants of our
solar system's formation
from about 4.6 billion years ago
they're made up of dust rock and ice and
they come in many sizes shapes and
levels of notoriety
maybe the most famous
is halley's comet
officially known as 1p halle
it's been observed for over 2 000 years
it was the first comet that astronomers
understood would make repeat visits
more specifically it was astronomer
edmund halley who figured this out back
in the 18th century
based on his calculations we know the
comet returns to our night sky just
about every 75 years
with its last flyby past earth happening
back in 1986
you can expect to see it again in 2061.
plenty of time for you to get ready to
hitch a ride on this icy rock
but beware
you wouldn't come back to earth until
the year 2136
2136
you'll have a lot of time to kill until
then so why not work on yourself using
skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes
ready to ignite your passion for
creativity and desire to learn new
skills whether you're learning to take
your career to the next level or grow
your side hustle this resource has
everything you need and with new classes
added every week available in multiple
languages well this is the time to
discover your true potential now i don't
know if you know this about me but i'm a
very passionate singer and i've been
working on my voice and with valerie
borehouse's singing like a star class
well i've been working on more than just
singing scales i've been looking for my
vocal personality yeah i'm learning to
find that balance between using too much
power and not sounding too breathy
trying to create my own unique sound
well that's my journey what interests
you well find out now because the first
1 000 people to use the link will get a
one month free trial of skillshare
that's thousands of classes with
teachers around the globe sharing their
knowledge for free
trust me you don't want to wait for
hallie's comment to come back before you
click on this offer
when you catch a ride aboard halley's
comet
you wouldn't be the first mission to
land on a comet
in 2004 the european space agency began
the rosetta mission to follow a comet on
its orbit around the sun
ten years later they were able to
successfully deploy a lander on the
comet's surface
but you would be the first to make a
human crude rendezvous with a comet
as your spaceship was closing in on
halley's comet the first thing you'd
encounter would be large amounts of gas
and dust
somebody get a house cleaner over here
this gas and dust combo form an
atmosphere that stretches behind the
comet for millions of kilometers
the particles of dust would be tiny only
one one millionth the size of a smoke
particle
and while you'd be protected inside your
spaceship
this would certainly make your approach
to the comet
a little more challenging
the dust particles would slam against
the shield of your ship at about 241
400 kilometers per hour
keep your fingers crossed that they
wouldn't rip off chunks of your craft
like they did to one unlucky space probe
back in 1986
if they did it could threaten the entire
mission
you could temporarily lose control of
your ship not to mention lose contact
with earth
needless to say with about 60 tons of
dust flying off the comet every second
you'd be in for a wild ride
but you'd finally land successfully on
the comet's nucleus which looks like a
potato or an unshelled peanut
it's here you'd be met with a big
surprise
first of all a comet's nucleus is what's
left of it after you strip away all the
dust and gas
and the nucleus of this particular comet
has a total surface area that is similar
in size to the hawaiian island of lanai
so
while you'd be traveling solo on your
mission you could have brought along
plenty of friends and family
maybe next time
but you'd be in for another surprise too
while you could have imagined that
something made of ice would be white and
bright you'd find the surface more like
an incredibly dirty snowball
that's thanks to a thick layer of dust
that's blacker than coal
this makes halley's comet one of the
least reflective objects in the solar
system
it only reflects about three percent of
the light that falls on it
as you begin to explore your
surroundings you want to make sure that
to do so with extreme caution
the surface gravity would be far too low
for you to walk around freely
if you jumped as high as you do on earth
you'd leap right off into space
hopefully you didn't imagine bouncing on
a trampoline on your journey around the
solar system
but that doesn't mean there's still not
a chance you could accidentally get
bounced off anyway
while we don't know exactly how fast
halley's comet rotates on its axis
there would be a period of transition
from day to night
the safest thing for you would be to
stay on the night side as much as you
can
as you already know from your hazardous
approach the comet is heated by the sun
as it heats up the gas and dust
particles are ejected off its surface
and they could take you with them
and you better buckle your seat belt
because the closer you get to the sun
the faster you'd be traveling
rounding this first destination on your
trip you'd be moving at about
196 000 kilometers per hour
hopefully you'd be equipping your
spacecraft with a good temperature
regulator because thanks to the heat
absorbing powers of that dusty black
surface
temperatures on holly's comet would
reach a blistering 87 degrees celsius
but as you head further away from the
sun things would become cooler and
cooler
traveling past mars the gas giants and
ice giants into the kuiper belt you'd
eventually have to deal with
temperatures as low as minus 220 degrees
celsius
if you planned to stay alive for the
duration of your trip you'd need
equipment to make breathable air and
drinking water from the comet's water
ice supply
to keep everything up and running you
could harvest electricity from the
kinetic energy of the comet itself
remember your journey is long
more than 75 years and as you reach the
edges of our solar system you'd also
slow
way down
here you'd be practically crawling at
only 3 200 kilometers per hour
and now as you begin the long journey
back to earth
you'd catch a front row glimpse at how
halley's comet is falling apart
with every loop it makes it loses
somewhere between one to three meters of
material
scientists estimate that comets can
survive a maximum of 1 000 trips around
the sun
but with 16 000 years and around 210
revolutions in its current orbit already
under its belt halle shows no
significant signs of aging
just don't invest too much in property
on this dark rocky mass
eventually your great great great
grandchildren could be left with nothing
but a crumbling comet being torn apart
every second
instead you could grab a plot of land on
the moon
but
that's a story
for another
what if